much of life here in tot Mahmut and the
Moroccan Atlas Mountains seems to belong
to the past but this new mosque is
pointing to the future the solar panels
on the roof produce clean energy here
reducing carbon emissions goes hand in
hand with creating jobs and businesses
for local people it is a most built 70%
by the people of the village and it is a
mosque during construction its
construction we managed to dream people
to develop their capabilities maybe to
be self-employed people in the future so
this is why for us it is a special
mosque clean energy helps combat climate
change Morocco is one of the most
affected countries half of the
population lives from agriculture but as
the climate grows drier people are
finding it harder to make ends meet the
government is well aware of that
with regard to climate change Morocco is
very vulnerable we suffer from the rise
of temperatures which obviously results
in dryads in addition to that we see
desert of vacation erosion of soil and
natural disasters to combat climate
change the government has set top goals
it wants to generate half the country's
energy from renewables by 2030 it's a
decision that will affect everyone and
can only happen with help from projects
like the mosque and Tod my met